prime minister thanks so much for taking
time with us
2022 was a big year a tumultuous year
there were so many world events going on
so let's start with that Russia is now
completely isolated by the West its war
in Ukraine is dragging on into a second
year causing incredible hardship for so
many people in Ukraine China has urged
de-escalation but at the same time is
strengthening its ties with Russia it
feels like a very unstable time so let's
start with China you describe it as an
increasingly disruptive world power is
China becoming the enemy of the West
no I think that's the wrong frame I
think China is growing to be the second
largest economy in the way that it is
the second largest economy in the world
growing perhaps to be the largest in the
coming coming decades
um and therefore it's a country we have
to deal with it's a country that
provides opportunities for economic ties
and cooperation in certain areas like
climate change and protecting nature
but at the same time it's a country that
has very different goals and very
different values than Canadians or than
than our Allied countries and we have to
be very very clear about where we can
look to cooperate or compete with China
and where we're going to need to
challenge China and and being direct and
open about that is I think a really
important thing the UK prime minister
said the Golden Era with the UK's
relationship with China is over and he
suggested that you know perhaps all the
trade and that approach that we've taken
over the last couple of decades has been
naive and even wishful thinking do you
agree with that I think there is a sense
that
we all sort of expected that more we
trade as you lift uh millions or
hundreds of millions of people out of
poverty into the middle class as China
has been able to do over the past
decades with economic liberalization
there is an expectation that it would
end up in free and open democracy the
way it has for us and people have now
questioned that that that's not
automatic and I think that hopefulness
that people had that with economic
advancement would come some of the
values that we build our societies
around there's a little more realism to
understand that China has a very
different frame and the Chinese
government specifically will
but it doesn't mean
that you can paint everyone with the
same brush because the Chinese Community
here in Canada are Chinese communities
in Western countries around the world
are thriving in in our uh in our open
liberal democracy so it really is a
focus on what the Chinese government
itself is choosing to do and keeping in
mind that Canada is a country with deep
people-to-people ties with Chinese
Chinese citizens and there are
opportunities for us to deepen those
economic ties while at the same time
highlighting very clearly the areas of
disagreement and the the
constructive approach we need to have to
making sure that the international order
or
Global rules and work
you are aware of the stories that Global
News has done the reporting on the fact
that you and other ministers have been
briefed on interference by China in
Canada's Democratic process are you
aware if the results in any any federal
writings in federal elections were
affected by that interference thank you
for for asking that question and and you
know thank you to the global for doing
such important work in highlighting the
ongoing challenges of interference by
China and other countries into Canada
into our Democratic systems but also
into the Chinese Canadian Community who
are always the the first targets of
Chinese Chinese government interference
what Canadians can be reassured by what
Canadians need to know is that we put in
place an independent panel of top
experts ahead of the 2019 election and
for the 2021 election to ensure that the
Integrity of our elections in every
riding across the country country was
not compromised and they can confirm
that our election Integrity helped
despite the fact that interference by
foreign countries including China is an
ongoing reality day in and day out in
our economies but our elections
held well I understand that there wasn't
I think the terminology there wasn't
significant impact was there any impact
though is it possible it didn't sway the
entire election but it may have swung
some writings no uh the the reporting is
at the the analysis shows that it didn't
have a significant impact on any of the
writings but of course
that there is any interference in our
democracies and our Democratic processes
is a very serious thing and that's why
we brought in measures we've continued
to strengthen measures we're going to
continue to make sure that our security
officials and agencies have the capacity
to counter interference to protect
communities that are more vulnerable to
foreign interference this is something
that Canadians expect and it's something
that we will do to continue to do do we
have the mechanisms and the laws in
place to really deal with this or do we
need new advises your government working
on new legislation yes we we need more
we always need more we we've done more
over the past few years than any
previous government when uh the previous
when the current leader of the
opposition was the elections Minister
under the previous government they
didn't do anything around foreign
interference so we started from next to
nothing to step up on protecting our
democracies of course it was in an era
following brexit and Trump and
allegations in France and elsewhere so
we saw the Foreign Affairs was starting
to be a real thing in all of our all of
our free and open countries and
therefore we built mechanisms and ways
for our agencies to lean in and take
care of that but there's always going to
be more to do because it keeps iterating
and we're going to keep doing it I think
the UK has actually introduced
legislation for an interference
legislation is there something in the
works here in Canada we're looking at a
range of things yes there's we're
looking at what our allies are doing
what's most effective what suits us
um but yeah we're going to be doing more
we're not the only country country
grappling with this of course in the UK
in July the MI5 and FBI held a joint
news conference which was quite
extraordinary for the heads of those two
organizations to talk about foreign
interference and they said that China is
the biggest long-term threat to our
economic and National Security they even
issued a public alert in the UK about a
woman working covertly on the half on
behalf of the Chinese Communist Party
who facilitated donations to an MP they
named the MP they named the woman is it
unreasonable to ask for more
transparency here in Canada
we know that Canadians need to be
reassured Canadians deserve to know
what's going on at the same time these
are matters of national security so we
do have to be careful about that but
what I've asked is for our top
intelligence officials and all the
people who have that information to
appear before parliamentary committee
and share as much as they possibly can
with Canadians understanding that the
base concern that everyone has is oh my
God we're our elections compromised by
Foreign interference and on that one we
can already say and are saying no they
have held but we're going to have to
make sure we're continuing to be
vigilant in the future can I ask you if
you've seen anything in our reporting
that is that is wrong are we getting
things wrong about the level of
interference because we have
information from csis investigations at
the interference in Canada allegedly
involved payments through intermediaries
to a clandestine Network that included
candidates affiliated with the Chinese
Communist party that China was placing
agents inside the offices of MPS
are you aware
now first of all it's really important
that journalists keep pushing and asking
questions and highlighting concerns
that's part of how our democracy works
well and it's really really important
um what I was and and people will
understand that I have to be very
deliberate when I talk about issues
around National Security and things that
we know to not compromise operations or
or various various things
but first of all ensuring that despite
all these uh these allegations in
reporting people know that our election
Integrity held is pretty important
pretty basis and I would I would put
emphasis on that that perhaps wasn't as
strong in the reporting because because
people are raising concerns and that's
fair
but the other thing I'll say and that's
I have said it
um
I never got in all the briefings and all
the serious briefings I got I never got
briefings on candidates receiving money
from China and that so that's something
that we know
getting further into details we know
there is ongoing interference in Canada
we're going to continue to try and
counter it
and ultimately our election Integrity
held and we're going to continue to try
and be open and transparent as much as
we can on some fairly delicate National
Security issues I think just just to
clarify the point I don't think our
reporting has ever said that you were
briefed specifically on candidates I'm
naming candidates but that a clandestine
network of covert kind of a covert
operation that funneled money again
people people ask me are you parsing
your words
um well I am being careful because we're
talking about very important issues of
National Security that involve
operations and issues that you have to
be be thoughtful about when when I get
Ultra top secret briefings on what's
going on there are limits on what I can
share with people and what I can but the
reality is that's why I've asked our top
intelligence officials to appear before
parliamentary committee to share what
they know but we also have a national
security
an intelligence Committee of
parliamentarians who are you know
cleared up to the top secret levels to
be able to dig into this on behalf of
all Canadians with that openness because
we created the NSI cop committee so that
parliamentarians could get the full top
secret briefings on these things and
reassure all Canadians that it's not a
partisan or government thing that they
are actually engaging in from all
different perspectives
all right let's move on to Russia's war
in Ukraine we're now heading into 2023
with no end in sight is this becoming a
war of attrition
um
if it is the combined uh steadfastness
and resolve of ukrainians and the West
together
will Outlast Russia we're seeing
tremendous tremendously negative impacts
on the Russian economy on the Russian
people because of Putin's terrible
decision to invade a neighboring country
but we are hopeful that it will not last
indefinitely
um
we are ready to stick with it as long as
possible and we know that for all the
challenges Canadians are facing with
inflation with food prices with Energy
prices
um it's much worse in Europe and it's
much worse for ukrainians when we're
dealing with higher prices in the
grocery store which is no fun and hurts
ukrainians are paying with their lives
and yet they are standing up against
this illegal bullying Invasion Behavior
by Russia that we all need to stand with
I think quite frankly when we release
the Ukraine sovereignty bonds a few
weeks ago so that ordinary Canadians
could support the Ukrainian people the
Ukrainian government we were overwhelmed
with the response they got overly
subscribed even though Canadians are
hurting because times are tough right
now they still chose to step up and
support Ukraine because they know that
it's the right thing to do do you think
there's anything on the horizon in 2023
that might change the equation here is
there are there any conditions under
which you think the west and NATO
countries should negotiate with Vladimir
Putin first of all it's not for us to
decide to negotiate with Vladimir Putin
ukrainians are paying with their lives
they are standing up to defend their
country their territorial integrity and
standing up for the principles that
underpin all of our democracies at the
same time it's them who get to decide if
they've had enough or if they want to
negotiate and every conversation I've
had with with Vladimir zielinski or
other ukrainians shows that they are
ready to stand strong and push back
against Russia as long as it takes and
we will stand with them as long as they
need to
I want to ask you about the cost of
living which you raised inflation is
hovering around seven percent you know
the Bank of Canada has raised interest
rates multiple times it's causing such
hardship for people in this country I
want to play you a clip if you don't
mind we've done multiple stories about
the cost of living and this one in
particular uh
surprised a lot of us so people are so
desperate they're coming here for food
but then they're asking you about
assisted suicide yes that's you're
having people ask you yes yes that I
when I say that this is an emergency in
the community
people who are living at the bottom
income percentile in our community are
talking to us now about taking their own
lives because it's too hard to be poor
any longer
that's the CEO of the Mississauga food
bank and we were stunned by that
what goes through your mind when you
hear that it's it's heartbreaking and it
deepens my resolve to do everything I
can to be there for people
um
inflation is a global phenomenon it's
linked to the war in Ukraine linked to
the disruption of Supply chains happened
by the pandemic and it's hitting
everyone around the world
the fact that it's hitting Canada
slightly less hard than most of our
fellow countries isn't even a tiny bit
of reassurance to any family who's
visiting a food bank for the first time
or or losing hope like that and that's
why we've had to step up and we will
continue to step up we've moved forward
with targeted supports doubling the GST
supports for six months moving forward
on cutting Child Care fees in half this
year which is making a huge difference
in the lives of a whole bunch of
families with young kids who we know are
extra vulnerable we're moving forward
with dental care for families that
otherwise couldn't afford it or would
have to make impossible choices to
afford it or giving a top up for uh for
low-income renters we're doing a number
of things and we'll continue to do more
but we know that
times are really tough for Canadians and
Canadians as we saw from all the
volunteers at the food banks are trying
to be there for each other and the
governments are working to try and be
there for people and we will make
through this because we've been through
tough times before but seeing people
lose hope like that is absolutely
heartbreaking and it just deepens my
resolve to continue to be stepping up
with direct supports for Canadians with
direct help for as many people as we can
direct supports you don't mean that kind
the pandemic style supports you don't
mean that no well one of the challenges
with an inflation crisis is we have to
be targeted in our supports if we were
to just pump lots more money into the
into the economy
um the prices of everything would go up
and there'd have to be even higher
interest rates so we need to make sure
we're targeting those supports but
that's why what we're doing for 11
million households with doubling the um
doubling the GST rebate what we were
doing with dental care what we're doing
with low-income rental supports what
we're doing with child care are all
things that that support people who need
that help
while we're getting through without
making the situation worse and getting
that balance right is is an ongoing
challenge for us that we're going to
continue to step up on because we know
and this is the this is the tough part
of this this year you can talk to
Canadians and hear from them they know
next year is going to be tough too
um it's it's going to be a tough year
global global recession fears uh slowing
down the global economy interest rates
continuing to be high inflation still
lingering it's going to be tough and
that's why we need to continue to stick
stick around for each other we need to
continue to be investing to support
people that's that's how we get through
this that's how we get to the other side
where some of the other things we're
doing like securing jobs in critical
minerals and and you know renewable
energy and green steel and and ensuring
better immigration policies that are
going to lead to more jobs these kinds
of things are going to lead us to a
better future in the coming year or two
but the coming winter is going to be
tough for people and that's where we
need to continue to pull together
I know that indigenous issues and
reconciliations Reconciliation has been
a huge priority from you from the day
you became prime minister you said that
there's no relationship more important
to you this year you visited a number of
First Nations including the chemist
equipment nation and the James Smith
Free Nation you were just there
how have those visits
um and seeing the grief the pain meeting
people in person how has that changed
you
you know in in 2015 when Canadians
elected our government with a clear
mandate to do more on reconciliation to
to Really lean in in a way that would
change the trajectory of the history of
this country
it was something genuine from all
Canadians there's no question about that
that was the unfinished business of
Confederation that we were happy to and
and and charged to take on
but when the unmarked Graves started to
be found this year
something that
indigenous communities had long known
that they had loved ones go off to
school and never returned something that
people who had read the reports The
Truth and Reconciliation Commission well
knew
but it's one thing to know it it's
another thing to see those Graves it's
another thing to walk amongst the
community where people
are being ripped open once again by the
loss in anguish
and it brings a renewed sense of
urgency to this of of
understanding that the
the harm
of
residential schools the harm of policies
of assimilation and indifference towards
indigenous peoples over decades and
centuries in this country
um
lasts today in very very real ways visit
the downtown east side of Vancouver
visit communities across the country
where poverty rates in indigenous
communities are are astronomical
compared to everywhere else those are
not only current challenges or
challenges anchored in in
generations of trauma passed on from one
to the next and that's where the work we
need to do to do two things not just to
invest and support those communities
but to make sure that as we're there to
support
those communities are directing their
own future are in charge of their
institutions are in charge of their
healing is the one thing that had never
been done before like governments have
always been trying to say okay here
we'll build you a new school we'll build
you a new Health Center we'll we'll fix
this we'll give you that
not enough asking of what is it that you
need and how do we give you what you
want and for not having asked for so
many generations or decades
um now getting the capacity to create
those answers is a slow process as well
so there's an urgency that infuses
everything we do on reconciliation but
there's a need to take the time to get
it right because we cannot just
perpetuate the kind of top-down
colonialism that got us into this
horrific situation in the first place do
you feel like you've done enough done
what you wanted to do towards
reconciliation God no there's so much
more to do I mean we have made huge
advances and you can see it and feel it
in a whole bunch of communities and one
of the communities that found the
unmarked Graves cow assess in
Saskatchewan I was a second Community to
uh to come forward
um when I went to visit them it was not
just to recognize that loss but it was
also to sign the very first agreement
under Child and Family Services that
meant kids at risk from that Community
would no longer be removed from that
community and put in foster homes you
know hundreds or even thousands of
kilometers away they would be kept in
their communities in their language in
their culture and that's the beginning
of changing the dynamic and the and the
the future for kids at risk because of
intergenerational trauma in
paternalistic colonial all that but
that's one Community there are so many
more to do so we're making real steps
but it's going to take time
one of the big events of 2022 was your
decision to invoke the emergencies act
in February how confident are you that
the inquiry into the use of the ACT will
agree that it was justified
um
I know
that as a government we took this
decision incredibly seriously we didn't
go into it lightly we made sure that we
move forward with time limited uh
targeted reasonable measures that didn't
bypass the Charter of Rights and
Freedoms so and we did it in a way that
we felt it was absolutely reasonable to
do now the inquiry but you were
operating in real time then right you
were making quick decisions and we know
that from seeing the inquiry and all of
the evidence that's come forward
retrospectively as that is picked over
that becomes a different you look at it
through a different lens right so I'm
saying if you look at it now through the
lens of several months later
do you feel you did the right thing is
that it was justified there's no
question um well first of all Heinz I
mean the commission is going to examine
whether with the information at the time
we made the right decision in the moment
because hindsight is a lot clearer on
that but even with hindsight we look
back
and it was resolved with no loss of life
with no serious injuries this was
something that had lingered for for
three weeks across the country where
there were weapons where there were
threats of violence where there were
real challenges to Citizens being harmed
in a whole bunch of different ways by
this the occupation in Ottawa that the
the economic impact of border crossings
and it was resolved in a very time
limited measured way
I am confident we did the right thing
but I really wish still we hadn't had to
I wish police could have solved it
without the federal government having to
step in that's what I wonder why in
retrospect would you have done anything
differently
in the leading up to that and then
during those four weeks you you at one
point said Canadians were angry at the
unvaccinated and that a fringe minority
of people hold unacceptable views you
know there's a sense that that fired up
more anger in retrospect
was that necessary for you to say I
think there was a lot of anger and
frustration on all sides because the
pandemic was in an unbelievably
difficult situation people were isolated
and fearful and and going through mental
health challenges and people were dying
people were dying because
we didn't have access to vaccines at
first and then people were dying because
they didn't get vaccinated and they were
putting other people at risk and I think
there was a lot of people a specific
term that people held unacceptable views
that's the thing that really seems to be
okay well then let me let me break that
down a little bit in in as clear way as
I can
there have always been people who for
various reasons personal cultural
various things have been hesitated to
get vaccinated I know yoga instructors
and vegan moms who haven't wanted to get
vaccinated for all sorts of realities
and that's fine and obviously that's
their choice nobody was forced to get
vaccinated and that's really important
however
there were people out there who were
actively spreading misinformation and
disinformation causing people to doubt
science even as doctors and leaders were
trying to convince people to do the
right thing get vaccinated there were
people out there trying to scare them
into not getting vaccinated and every
family I heard about who was sitting
beside the bedside of a loved one
unvaccinated dying of covid because they
didn't get vaccinated regretting
bitterly that they'd listen to the
YouTube channel that told them that the
vaccines were more danger or more
dangerous than the virus
um that is something that I think needed
to be called out and and calling people
out who are putting at risk the lives of
Canadians and the well-being of
Canadians is something that is the job
of a prime minister
can I ask you to reflect a little bit on
public life and being in politics you've
been an MP for 15 years you're going
into your your eighth year as prime
minister yeah
um I want to show you a flashback video
it's a little bit of a yeah well it'll
be okay facial hair do I have on that
one I got
my God
thank you so much
[Applause]
when you watch that do you
do you reflect on how much the political
climate has changed between your when
you're first elected and now
you could have shown the opening of my
first campaign office in 20
2008 I guess in my very first election
where we had 150 people outside
chanting and protesting me in politics
there are always going to be people in
this extraordinary diverse country who
disagree sometimes quite passionately
with whoever's in power
and that's a really important thing in
our country it's really important that
people get to express themselves and
there are continuing to be rooms that I
can go into or are parts of the country
I go to where people are incredibly
happy to see me and more than people are
are unhappy to see me but you can't
govern for eight years now
and do significant things as we have and
keep everybody on side all the time
there are going to be you know people
who disagree with any position that we
take I totally understand that but it
seems to me the degree of vitriol is I
have covered you over since you became
prime minister is is worse now and I
don't mean not only for you I mean that
for all the political leaders that being
in public life now you have to have a
thicker skin I think than you did
a couple of decades ago I mean it is in
your face it is uh you know the F
Trudeau chance and the and the flags and
I know that you know the leader of the
opposition and the leader of the NDP
have faced a lot of hatred too what does
that tell you about public life in
Canada
um
it tells me we need more people more
good people to get involved in politics
and it's hard to convince people to get
involved in politics now it's harder to
find good candidates it's harder to
convince people to step forward and
represent their communities but because
of that the one thing I also have found
over the past months and year as as
we've seen more vitriol from some
quarters
is more and more people stepping up to
say thank you for what you're doing I
don't agree with everything you're doing
but thank you for doing it in really
thoughtful ways I know it's not easy but
you're doing the best you can you're
doing a good job and it really matters
and
Canadians didn't do that as much before
as they do now because it is a reaction
to the fact that there is a lot of
negativity in politics but
it's all more reason to stay focused on
what I got elected for what everyone
gets elected for is to serve your
community and make things better for for
your neighbors you're going into your
eighth year do you ever think I just
want to get out of this
I think the first time I thought I've
made a terrible mistake was the weekend
after I first got elected back in 2008 I
mean anyone who's doing any challenging
job will also go through Reflections on
oh you know what's you know how much
more can I do but I I realize how much
there is to do and
what we've been able to accomplish with
an extraordinary team of diverse
Canadians serving this country going
through some really tough times I mean
we started with Trump then we had a
pandemic and then we had convoys and war
in Ukraine
um you know there are there are really
big issues around the world right now
and Canadians
you know as I travel around the world
and talk with other world leaders
um they sort of Look At Me With Envy
because I get to serve Canadians and
Canadians are incredibly thoughtful and
positive and ambitious and we're well
positioned yes even though we're facing
really tough times right now like
everyone around the world
we're positioned we just we just hit
second in the world on battery supply
chains we're positioned to be a supplier
of energy in a net zero world that that
decades from now is going to be
essential we're moving towards green
steel green aluminum at a time when the
world needs it we've got a diverse open
population open to immigration and
growing population uh more than our G7
counterparts the world looks at Canada
and goes oh my God you guys are well
positioned and of course for us here at
home we don't pay much attention to that
we focus on the challenges we're facing
but there is so much to be proud of in
this country there's so much to know
that we are capable of meeting and
conquering any challenge that comes our
way that for me it is the greatest
privilege of my life to be able to serve
Canadians in this role and to know that
I'm going to get to do it for many more
years
all right prime minister thank you thank
you daughter